you don't know yes or no if the laptop I
don't have any idea I have no idea so it
could have been yours of course
certainly it there could be a laptop out
there that was stolen from me there
could be that I was hacked it could be
that there was the that it was Russian
intelligence it could be that it was
stolen from me
Russian disinformation Hunter Biden's
lawyers admitting that the contents of
the infamous laptop are in fact real and
they are now calling on state and
federal agencies to investigate the
unauthorized access claiming the first
son is the victim of quote failed dirty
political trick Hunter's attorney
insists that this does not confirm that
the laptop is the president's son just
the data that's been spread widely so
the disclosure is a big black eye for
the 51 former Intel officials who
dismissed the story as Russian
disinformation right before the 2020
election
as I and several of my former colleagues
have pointed out publicly that it does
bear the Hallmarks of Russian
disinformation to me this is uh this
classic
textbook Soviet Russian tradecraft at
work and so all of a sudden two two and
a half weeks before the election this
laptop appears somehow
somehow so then Presidential candidate
Joe Biden used what those Intel chiefs
were saying to swat down questions about
his own son
yes yes yes God love you man you're a
one-horse opponent there's nothing too
many of that
nothing doing that it's all a smear
there are 50 former National
Intelligence folks who said that what
this he's accusing me of is a Russian
plan
and finally there's the media who was
quick to dismiss the laptop
for all we know these emails are made up
or maybe some are real and others are
fakes we don't know so we're supposed to
believe that Hunter Biden and a drunken
stupor dropped off his laptop ongoing
Russian disinformation effort whether
that meeting email for example is real
in the midst of this
um do you think stuff like that could
just have been planted in there and be
completely fake
and so we're supposed to believe uh as
the famous phrase goes that the contents
of the laptop are real but the laptop is
not his Jesse Yeah Hunter is like the
guy that calls 9-1-1 and says someone
stole my drugs
your drugs we were waiting months for
Hunter to go on offense we kept on
hearing he was building this great legal
team and he was going to start hitting
back at his critics so we're waiting and
then last night we got all these letters
and the strategy is I confessed the
laptops mine and then 24 hours later he
goes actually it's not never mind if
it's someone else's so he's saying they
did hold ten percent for the big guy he
did try to get his dad to fire the
prosecutor and he did take Chinese money
it's like O.J saying someone stole my
knife oh really your knife OJ oh not my
knife just someone's knife so let me get
this straight Hunter goes into the well
not Hunter maybe someone stole it went
into the laptop repair shop gives the
laptop signs a document it's a contract
it says if you don't pick this thing up
in 90 days it's not yours anymore
let me understand Hunter's defense
Hunter's saying
he might have gone into the laptop
repair shop but the laptop repair shop
guy was blind so we can't confirm it was
him or someone stole the laptop brought
it to the repair shop forged Hunter's
signature and then forgot to pick it up
so someone stole the laptop that was in
his and he's saying Daddy Daddy help me
he's like Karen you know those guys that
get bounced from the bar in college
don't you know who my father is he is
going to sue the pants off you he's
calling on his father's prosecutors to
put his guys in Jail arrest to the guys
who stole the laptop that wasn't mine
I've never seen anything like this and
this kills Joe Biden's defense Joe
Biden's been saying this whole time we
have an independent Department of
Justice
it's totally independent we don't get
involved at all and then Hunters asking
his father's prosecutors to arrest the
October surprise guys
they've been trying to keep Joe and
Hunter separated for this entire Scandal
and Hunter just made him a sandwich not
good judge there are reports that the
president's team did not agree with this
legal strategy I could imagine why well
first of all I mean the fact that they
came out last night Wednesday night and
they said that uh the the laptop does
indeed belong to Hunter but then today
it's like we're not so sure it belonged
to him but maybe the information
belonged to him I mean so then who are
you representing you know if you're not
if you're saying the laptop didn't
belong to Hunter but the the craziest
part you have to pull back from all of
this think about what we have witnessed
for two years the White House denied the
fact that the president even knew that
his son had any business dealings in
foreign countries we didn't know whether
or not that laptop or we were told it
had nothing to do with Hunter Biden it
was Russian discipline information and
who told us this 51 intelligence agents
agencies uh agents I should say five of
them were former heads of the CIA
Brennan Clapper these are people who
were given National Security information
access these are people who are sold to
the highest bidder or the highest
ideology and then the social media the
mainstream media and everyone else
blocked this information from us this is
the is this is pretty much what they do
in third world countries I mean America
has to step back and realize that we
have been subjected to a fraud he wants
to talk about a dirty political trick
the only political trick was by this
White House this President saying it's
Russian disinformation and by the way
what made them think that they could get
away with it what made them think they
could get away with it is because they
were all in on it now and now but not
now but now he wants to say I'm a victim
Hunter Biden wants the same effect
you're a victim you went around Europe
with a vacuum cleaner sucking up
millions of dollars from China the
Ukraine as and and Russia you slept with
every woman you could find and you want
to tell us that you're a victim you got
a diamond from the Chinese a hundred
thousand dollars spending money you're
sleeping with everyone you want but
you're a victim it's all been a fraud on
us what's the media to do now Greg well
I think what they're going to do is
they're going to shift the narrative so
that we never said it was fake
we just said it was Russian
disinformation and you know what it can
be both because Russians will use real
material in disinformational ways that's
their way through this so the laptop you
know it might be Hunters but it's being
exploited by the Russians that's what we
were talking about that is what you're
going to hear from every one of those 51
or 52 until when they're going to be
pulled before a committee because they
have to be because we have to we have to
see what's behind that what what was the
coordination behind that it's the same
thing with the with the uh the bearing
of the laptop where you saw this
required collusion Tech Industries media
Chamber of Commerce the Democratic party
to take out Trump they did the same
thing with these with with this like 51
group they got them together it's
beginning I'm beginning to feel like
maybe Tucker's onto something about
Watergate I'm beginning to question
everything and to your point about him
being a hunter being a victim if he had
his theme song it would be Sympathy for
the Devil because he he his play a
throughout all of this has been sympathy
and it's it's obvious people in the
throes of addiction deserve sympathy but
the problem with addiction and the
problem with drug users and the problem
with narcissism you can't tell the
difference you can't tell the difference
whether he's in the throes of addiction
or the throes of his own narcissism so I
won't feel sorry for a guy who can't
control himself you know when he's had
so many opportunities to change and he I
mean the guys didn't just sleep with his
brother's wife you know he slept with
the sister of his brother's wife I don't
even think CNN will hire him now yeah
and you see the meeting you see the
media freaking out about George Santos
man this guy Santos couldn't hold
Hunter's jock not that he should
no one should do that Geraldo does his
legal team not realize that this would
open him up to Discovery uh Abby Lowell
is a forceful determined lawyer he's as
good as they come so whatever opening is
there he will uh he will exploit it but
I want to just Echo what the judge said
about uh about John Brennan and James
Clapper and uh these other uh men and
women with whom we invested enormous
respect and and and Trust as the head of
Our National Intelligence and to sign a
document like that which is clearly
political it is a ploy to distract
people uh to just lead you away from the
real story which is the the
disintegration of the life of the of the
the first son here uh it is so sad to
see uh how his life just turned to such
crap how is it crap tell me how is it so
you know he's got away with everything
he's selling art for a half a million he
said he's he's banging everything he's
good he's he if you think he stopped
doing drugs you're nuts well I I agree
that once a junkie always a junkie but
what happened to this guy is pathetic
and it reflects on his father I hope
that it weighs on his conscience but let
me just address very briefly the legal
issue here there is no doubt but that
computer was abandoned as Jesse says
there's a 90-day contract he signed it
so the physical computer is clearly the
property of the Mac repair guy and
whatever whom he made a deal it is a
much closer question as to the contents
of the computer
did he surrender his copyright
when he surrendered his computer now
there's nothing about the contents in
the in the contract so I think that if
for instance you wanted to do a
documentary a damning documentary about
the president United States and his his
Dysfunctional Family
the question is whether or not you can
use that material we are using a
cavalierly there he is smoking crack
there he is with the hooker here he is
doing this that and the other thing but
uh the whether or not you can do do a
commercial on it uh is uh is another
matter entirely and it will be
interesting to see how with Abby Lowe
leading the charge he starts going after
everybody now everybody who has used it
uh you know in in media and in
entertainment and in comics and so forth
it'll be a fascinating but the more he
fights the more he's going to keep this
on page one
page one indeed Tyrone and Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now